qui se crée
c'est souvent lié
à des pierres qui viennent en appui sur
la fonte et qui finissent par les
mouvements de terrain
par cassé voilà l'une des canalisations
endommagées responsable de perte d'eau
colossale du château d'eau au robinet de
la commune il y a 3 ans français
perdaient la moitié de son eau potable
jusqu'à 144 mètres cubes d'eau par jour
pour un déficit conséquent normalement
le budget haut est un budget annexe qui
doit s'autofinancer avec les recettes et
les dépenses
et là la trésorerie on regarde notre
déficit au niveau budget annexe nous a
autorisé à
verser du budget général au budget out
30000 euros voilà ce qui nous a permis
de combler le déficit
particularité de Français sont
territoire est étendu il compte 17
hameaux et ferme répartis sur 1700
hectares et relié par 9 km d'un réseau
d'eau vieillissant coûteux à remplacer
installez en différents endroits de la
commune pour mesurer la consommation
secteur par secteur de simples vannes
permettent d'identifier les fuites donc
là on a un compteur qui nous dit que la
consommation d'eau les grosses fuites
qui nous ont vraiment pénalisées ça a
duré presque deux ans et après on a donc
décidé d'investir dans plusieurs
endroits ou 4 22 secteurs munis de
compteur et là après dans les dans la
semaine qui a suivi on a trouvé
en réparant les fuites français
retrouvent un taux de perte inférieur à
10% mais à plus long terme s'oppose la
question du remplacement des
canalisations pour la plupart en fonte
posée dans les années 50 irréalisable
sans soutien financier à partir de là un
secteur le secteur de Villeneuve là où
ça a tendance à casser relativement
régulièrement on avait envisagé en 2009
ou 2010
de refaire une partie de ce réseau là un
kilomètre et demi et à l'époque ça nous
coûtait de nous réécouter 250000 euros
hors taxes on n'avait pas les moyens
donc on a préféré partir sur des
réparations plutôt que d'investissement
le coup de pouce pourrait venir de
l'État français figure parmi les 170
communes prioritaires du plan haut du
gouvernement annoncé en mars sans
nouvelles depuis l'équipe municipale
espère ne pas voir les annonces
s'évaporer durant l'été